bonjour à tous donc je suis beagle c'est
à dire danseuses de ce que l'on appelle
communément le break dance mais qui
s'appelle plutôt dix boeing ou breaking
historiquement parlant le terme
breakdance a été inventé par les médias
ce qui m'emmène aujourd'hui vous faire
une petite présentation sur le
décryptage du monde hip hop qui vise
notamment à donner des éclairages sur le
hip hop incluant césar et sa culture
bush dans ce dans ce décryptage je vais
vous présenter je vais vous inviter à
découvrir ou redécouvrir l'histoire du
hip hop et certains termes du
vocabulaire et hip hop et non je ne
terminerai pas toutes mes phrases par
wesh pas besoin de compter je vous
regarde
tout d'abord qu'est-ce que le hip hop
lorsque j'ai commencé le hip hop il ya
un peu plus de 15 ans parce que j'avais
15 ans pas la peine de compter il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de cours de hip hop
puisque la plupart apprenait dans la rue
et puis au fur et à mesure donc l'écho
2002 de hip hop se sont démultipliés les
sans abri oublier l'histoire du hip hop
mais cette histoire est très importante
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier que le
hip hop ne se résume pas à de la danse
ou du rap le hip hop c'est un mouvement
culturel et artistique
c'est d'abord un mouvement culturel qui
est née à new york dans les années 1970
dans un contexte de drogue de violence
notamment à manhattan où les ruines
étaient plus sûres c'est l'époque de la
ségrégation ou c'est l'époque où l'on
rejette les personnes de couleur
ces personnes de couleur sont parqués
dans des ghettos le bronx brooklyn
harlem
et c'est dans une ambiance et dans une
ambiance de méfiance envers ses voisins
d'arnaqué à l'assurance
tout cela en quelque sorte favoriser la
naissance d'une culture des guides des
ghettos qui prendra le nom
hip hop et c'est le 11 août 1973 très
exactement en 1520 cédric avenue ou dans
le bronx que tout a commencé
ce jour s'il dit campbell s'apprête à
fêter son anniversaire et elle demande à
son frère
cliff pemble alias dj kool herc de gérer
le sont à partir de 2,7 de cette date
donc le mouvement et le mouvement
culture hip hop s'est construit sous
l'égide du rassemblement avec des
messages de paix et de tolérance
alors que c'est que ce que les membres
de j pop sont des jeunes en perte de
repères drogue violence des gangs
le mouvement est riche des valeurs
universelles dont cinq principales peace
unity
oui spect knowledge having fun et ses
valeurs sont portés par un autre monde
membre fondateur et qui s'appelle afrika
bambaataa qui est lui-même ancien chef
de gang et avec dj dans le master flash
dj kool herc et afrika bambaataa forme
ce que l'on appelle le la sainte trinité
du hip hop le mouvement hip hop est
également au mouvement artistique qui
comprend le rap c'est à dire le champ
qui comprend le graff le dessin le dj
mené à la musique
le m singh c'est-à-dire l'animation au
micro et le break la danse lorsque j'ai
commencé à briquet il ya plus de 15 ans
je ne connaissais pas tout ça c'est au
fur et à mesure de mes rencontres avec
les personnes du milieu que j'ai
commencé à être curieuse et cette
curiosité m'a conduite à écrire un livre
qui s'appelle les danses de la culture
hip hop qui est paru aux éditions
l'harmattan
et comment j'en suis arrivée à écrire un
livre
et bien tout a commencé ici en quelque
sorte à l'université jacob bellecombette
puisque en 2016
j'ai été contacté par une maison
d'édition qui m'a proposé
de publier mon livre de publier un livre
sur son mémoire de master 1 et c'était
sur les particularités de la
communication d'un musée et ensuite
après deux ans de recherche et
d'écriture j'ai décidé de sortir un
autre livre cette fois sur la culture
hip hop et la maison d'édition
l'harmattan a accepté de le publier et
ensuite donc la maison d'édition a été
contacté par la production de france
inter mme j'étais l'invité de la bande
originale à l'occasion du film break que
je vous conseille dont il était l'invité
en tant qu'experte de la culture hip hop
pourquoi je vous conseille ce film break
parce qu'il montre bien l'esprit battles
et c'est ce qu'on va voir maintenant
dans ce décryptage
on va voir ce qu'est exactement le
battle le battle est né sous les landes
afrika bambaataa qui lui-même je voulais
dit tout à l'air est un ancien chef de
gang
il a eu un tournant dans sa vie à la
mort de son cousin
il a décidé de complètement changer et
de monter une organisation envers les
jeunes qui s'appelle la zulu nation
cette organisation a voulu transformer
l'énergie négative en est nazi positif
et c'est là tous les sens du battle
s'est transformé les gangs en crau c'est
à dire en groupes artistiques
j'ai moi même participé à quelques
battle los connaissent pas et ce que
j'en garde c'est vraiment l'ambiance
bienveillante
vous allez me dire une ambiance belle
bienveillante en battle alors c'est pas
qu'en regardant le croupier en face pour
cela ils sont là pour vous déstabiliser
mais quand vous avez votre crew qui est
derrière vous quand vous avez le m6 qui
a qui vous encouragent quand vous allez
tout le public autour de vous qui vous
encouragent la sec 1
septième plus de la bienveillance et
puis après mètre 60 et l'autre crew qui
est acquis devant vous et là vous pouvez
aussi essayer de déstabiliser l'autre
point de rassemblement hip hop c'est le
safe
alors avant le cypher hip hop il
existait le jem dans la culture
africaine
le jeune homme et est constitué de
personnes formant un cercle et
encourageant une personne qui se
présentait au milieu pour chanter pour
danser donc c'est le même principe dans
les sypher hip hop
que ce soit en rap ou en danse c'est
c'est avant tout un lieu de libre
expression
moi j'ai souvent mes petits élèves qui
ont peur de se présenter au milieu du
cercle pour danser il me dit souvent
oui mais il est dit moi j'ai peur qu'on
se moque de moi ils ont raison les
petits bouts mais le cercle c'est
vraiment pas un endroit on est là pour
se moquer c'est vraiment un endroit
aussi on a vite vu côté donc tous les
sens et ben oui gigote dans tous les
sens et personne ne vous dira rien
normalement dans la fifa dans le
siffleur que vous avez qu'il ya derrière
moi je me trouvais à new york à
l'occasion à m
à l'occasion du notw a organisé qui
retrace les lieux emblématiques du
hip-hop et du coup ce qui m'a fortement
frappé dans d'entente ans écroué un qui
se sont organisés notamment le coût à
new york où il y avait des personnes de
différents
horizon c'est que nous avions tout ça en
commun les codes du hip hop et
aujourd'hui je vous en présenter deux de
code vip up le style et le blaze alors
le style
pour vous donner un petit aperçu un
petit résumé
j'aime bien donner cette phrase du
groupe de rap français sur votre
casquette basket mais dans le droit
chemin
vous l'avez peut-être déjà entendu non
snipers pris pour cible ces vieux la
corde mais ça résume bien la cie la
situation je vais vous raconter une
petite anecdote pour la promo de mon
livre les dans la culture hip hop
j'étais présente sur un salon est comme
mon âme comme à mon habitude pour tous
les événements hip hop je m'étais look
et hip hop et là je regardais les
personnes qui dans bull et il y avait
les personnes qui s'arrêta à chaque
stand et qui 2,15 à iv à mon stand dette
on évite le regard d'un grand tour joël
m'a pas vu et qui passait et je me suis
dit si j'étais resté classique
si j'avais porté un petit tailleur mais
ça m'arrive emporté un d'un monde autre
vie professionnelle je me dis que les
choses se seraient passées différemment
vous vous imaginez bien que ce jour là
j'ai pas vendu beaucoup de livres donc
tout ça pour vous dire que le style hip
hop old school est en général un style
qui fait peur mais il faut savoir que
que les vêtements hip hop de l'époque
sont plaints de symbolique
je vais vous donner des exemples parmi
les symboliques dans le dans les codes
vestimentaires jeep à vous avez des
accessoires de luxe et détaille ce soir
à taïwan parmi les accessoires de luxe
vous avez par exemple le quasar ce sont
des grosses lunettes que les jeunes qui
n'avaient pas d'argent se procurer des
copies de ces de ses marques par exemple
sur quel sur canal suite à new york au
niveau des accessoires under guad les
les accessoires du monde carcéral était
très portée et la tenue orange était
très à la mode
vous avez également pu le remarquer que
les membres du hip hop se cache souvent
le visage derrière différents terre des
casquettes des bobs des bonnets
moi ça me cachais pas trop le visage les
capuches et s'éteint mais il faut savoir
que ces codes vestimentaires sont portés
dont par les jeunes qui en les portant
ont un sentiment de fierté fierté envers
ses origines et aubaine
ensuite l'autre l'autre code que nous
avons dans le hip hop c'est le blaze
alors qu'est ce que le blaze le bla
c'est le surnom qu'on se donne entre
membres du hip hop
moi mon blaze c'est milady il m'a été
attribuée vers 2013 paraît de l'ops
quant aux red sox m'a proposé ce blaze
j'ai été tout de suite très ravi j'ai
trouvé ce nom très élégant et puis
l'appropriation a été pour moi une sorte
de défi mais je pense que c'est souvent
le cas un puisque en fait quand on nous
donne un blaze
il faut qu'on se l'approprient et est en
fait le blaze faire monter certains
traits de notre personnalité plus ou
moins caché que l'on cherche à
développer dans notre art les plus
grands noms du hip hop ont un blaze dj
kool herc doit son nom à ses racines
jamaïcaines
d'où le mot cool et à sa grande taille
et des reculs qui qui se transforme en
dix minutes if erc afrika bambaataa elle
choisit son nom en hommage à ses
ancêtres africains dj dans le master
flash était connu pour sa dextérité à
faire passer les disques dans le dos et
vous avez le bboy quiz il est gay qui
était aussi connue pour la rapidité de
son jeu de jambes
donc voila un petit peu les pauvres pour
le blaze a maintenant entrons dans le
vif du sujet les danses hip
donc moi j'ai dansé un petit peu partout
et j'ai commencé à danser mjc j'ai dansé
quand j'étais à la fac ici ou jamais
pris l'option sport hip hop et ensuite
donc j'ai dansé un petit peu à
l'étranger à barcelone à lincoln
et puis quand j'ai commencé à travailler
j'ai continué à danser et j'ai dansé par
exemple lorsque j'ai travaillé au
conseil au conseil général de la
haute-savoie m6 je me suis inscrit dans
une dans une école de danse hip hop
d'ailleurs ben eager poussines
donc voilà j'ai pas mal j'ai pas mal
danser et je suis enfin disons que je
préfère plutôt les danses dites hautes
school qui font plus partie de mon de
mon domaine d expertise et pas miley
parmi elles on a le break
alors qu'est ce que le break et bien le
break c'est ça
[Musique]
alors le break nso la east coast parce
que vous avez sûrement entendu parler de
des petites guéguerres isco swayze cost
en rap et bien c'est un peu pareil en
danse donc le bret fait partie de la
east coast et toutes les autres dans son
parti de la west coast et parmi ces
autres danses on a le bol s'installe
chez un mélange de popping et de bukavu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci donc hormis ces deux danses on a
le look in donc le lot qui est la plus
ancienne danse du hip hop c'est à dire
qu'elle a une existence avant d'avoir
intégré le hip-hop et le locking c'est
ça
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ensuite la dernière danse qui fait
vraiment partie des danses dites au
school c'est le freestyle office le
freestyle c'est la danse des clubbers de
la west coast par excellence et ça donne
ça oh j'ai fait quelque chose qu'il
fallait pas jour problème technique
[Musique]
merci
donc hormis ces danses
vous en avez d'autres mais je ne vais
pas te saouler présentait donc
aujourd'hui je suis moi je suis co
fondatrice d'une association qui
s'appelle au lieu d' ans et qui a pour
objet justement la promotion et la
diffusion des dance et hip hop
donc nous nous sommes nous aurions nous
participons à des stages à des
conférences et notre dernier projet
c'est l'écriture de postes que l'on que
l'on met sur les réseaux sociaux sans
appel sur les traces hip hop et je vous
invite à les consulter
et pour finir on affirme en musique
je vous demande de vous lever non non
c'est l'heure de la sieste vous vous y
attendez non cheriet leçon
m
et on va tous m libre et la débauche
vrai
une simple rotation sur mon travail
ouais tous
[Musique]